but then I try to think like I don't
really care what they think this is the
therapy working so I would like to
Heineken they're like okay but then I
tell I've told my wife ahead of time to
order a Heineken and she wants coffee
because she has no fear yeah so she
orders a Heineken I chug them both put
both cans on her try and go what there's
been tabloid Dana Carvey wife oh sure
but I only need a few I maybe three or
four and then I just drink water and
fight the rest I'm like I'm like an hour
flight oh no no no 6-hour flight yeah
well we had to story came out of Hawaii
this before the volcano there's two
storms or intersecting and remember and
so it was three hours of bump and grind
and all the pressure of get the food out
no don't try to get the food out cuz I'm
and trays and spaghetti sauce we don't
need that yeah it's fine have it safety
goes ahead of airline food yeah just
slightly well and it's just someone with
a baby who's in the aisle and it's
really rocking and rolling and they're
holding it and checking for stuff
overhead don't do that don't be that
person
and what I do is because I used to have
miss fearing stuff so I'm always opening
because no one looks out the window it's
all dark yeah so I open it and look to
see if we're outside the storm then I
close it then I open it then I close it
and it goes on for hours and a woman
hopefully Atlantic oh you scared me you
were just so fit what were you looking
at I said I have a fear of flying yeah I
had four Heinekens in me I hadn't used
the bathroom in six hours
I was looking for atmospheric changes so
I would know regardless irregardless to
see out signs whether I can use the
restroom we wouldn't be ever seen if
this really trans - it's the YouTube
movement not me - but all of this yeah
you - yeah I and that and that's really
what the Internet has done for whatever
weird thing that has happened you or you
think has only happened to you if you
put it out on social media someone's
like oh my god you to you to you to you
to have a thank you - I just want to get
so famous like Katy Perry - where you
can have forty five million followers on
Twitter and you can literally one
morning -
what's up and 45,000 people will retweet
that yeah you know or she'll just put
hay or like had a sandwich today oh it's
been thinking about changing my hair
color ninety thousand retweets well it's
great it but at the point I am on the
planet and where I am and what I've done
with these shenanigans yeah you know I'm
doing a little video and I rarely do it
a lot of people was gone
hey look yes like 8,000 views and then
I'll check Katy Perry and it's like 120
million am I really doing it well is it
Twilight Zone away and we're actually
doing it yeah yeah well you just need
more cleavage there Dana yeah let me
process that I root for all the young
people I just look at the work ethic and
the drive I'm like I don't judge it to
me it's like but echo you know it's an
algorithm and a drumbeat and you know I
grew up with Zeppelin and and Neil Young
so it's hard for me as a grumpy old man
to relate to the music but I love the
effort I love that you said on your
Conan appearance when you met you were
doing somebody stayed up till eight oh
yeah because it's on TBS a day uh why do
the promos for it you know oh that's
right yeah that's what also I love
Connie's the best here and uh and you're
you guys are always so fun together but
you were doing you were mentioning how
Obama saying little rocket money yeah
right and like how much cooler he wasn't
the songs he's saying and what would oh
right sing about green or something or
well it's again it's always the
juxtaposition I I do have a new bit were
the next president would be the most
boring human being that's ever been
invented sure like literally hi my
name's Brian I won't say or do anything
very abrupt I will consider every moment
you know but with Obama but that and the
cool part of Obama was you can see it on
YouTube people singing and singing well
he did out green know and then he did
once we're gonna come together as a
country and then all the pausing like a
very and the church goes crazy and then
you know in my thought what would Trump
sing it makes me laugh I just came upon
me and I know it's stupid but the cook
in the Grippit
but they're a good to great
Adams family let it did let it one of
the catchiest things some guy got paid a
lot of money don't get 1965 yeah you got
anything that's catchy we need an Addams
Family theme doesn't have snidely
doot-doot doot-doot
yeah but let me ask you guys a pop
culture questions cuz I said it one
night to the audience as a joke like no
one knows the lyrics after they're
kookier and the creepy the entire
audience knew it what their kooky and
their creepy mysteriously in spooky
ookey their even kind of how many things
rhyme with creepy like it's only gotta
be like I heard the other night I said
to the audience cuz I was doing Nixon
you know the racist Nixon I mean he was
president we've had crazy presidents I'm
sure him with Twitter
I don't like Jews hashtag yarmulke so
the audience on the west side goes dead
silence yeah so I had to go wait a
minute I'm doing an impression right of
an anti-semitic person I'm not an
anti-semitic well doubt well not yet and
then and then the ultimate of that is
the Jeff Dunham territory
where you go I'm not racist the puppet
is yeah oh did any puppeteer mentors
ever reverse it where where I'm racist
here a pub there the races as well and
the puppets a straight man I don't know
why no one ever did that hey look at
those tits I've never seen that in and I
think it's literally the worry where
it's like no no I'll make the puppet
racist because then I'm not exact and
though they just assume that that's how
puke that's how people are gonna view
sexist racist yeah you know what I love
though in that guy hey don't do that
clip though then until you said people
didn't really respond and then you said
whoa nineteen much to the to the
audience like oh that's their millennial
in this yeah and okay Conan just had a
very sweet genuine laugh at that and I
laugh at that because it was it was a
very like obvious like yeah like the
collectively sometimes as it doesn't a
show doesn't understand I get the
biggest hit the thing that makes me the
happiest now is the audience being quiet
like if a guy's stone-faced and I'm
doing Jimmy Carter and having a nervous
breakdown
peanut butter his head I got peanut
butter half peanut butter pants and the
idea he has to listen to it right look
at me is the funniest and young people
will laugh but they don't know who I'm
doing a lot of that time but I love it
when they're just laughing anyway
because by the way did you see the
interview with the juror from from The
Cosby Journal he said that he voted
guilty and they and they said like oh
did Cosby's reputation have anything to
play with that he goes I don't know who
Bill Cosby is oh he's 22 years old and
he does like he's like I don't know he's
a celebrity I don't know what he's done
and I just have to take a pause and go
well [ __ ] what has he done in the last
you know he's on the road you know that
he used to compete with me I did I
played Washington State in Spokane and
the guy goes Cosby is here for the last
you know parents weekend a big house oh
that's how you competed with Cosby Jesus
try it
III just got very scared my like I used
to compete with kasi I'm like oh god
this is not gonna go well I had a PEZ
dispenser full of quaaludes
he had a super soaker I couldn't compete
but he was so hard
Eliz Regis I'm at a good drop what makes
me interested in Cosby is two things one
is of Michael Jackson let's just say you
like children
you create an amusement park yeah right
and then to draw them in sure so if you
like to do Cosby's activity because he
did not talk like that in the sixties so
it evolved into I would have taken a
pill from a guy
okay that's good
well no if he does get off and gets out
he's like 100 to still be doing it it's
an exaggerated kospi yeah yeah it but
it's just but not really it's insane to
me to think that there was someone on
that jury that goes ah who's that guy
like it's just madness it's just like
what you were commenting about there's
so much [ __ ] there's not enough like you
can't there's nothing exists nothing
everything yeah it's just there's too
much of everything
Jesus Hitler maybe Trump in a thousand
years who you could say two people on
the street who was Jesus who's that who
was Trump Wow Trump that's like crossed
over into that exelon huh Jesus and
Hitler me marry [ __ ] kill my favorite
thing to do which I'll do tonight now is
my new show again where a lot of the
people just stare at me yeah
so it's Trump getting the Nobel Prize
which I broke first and now they're
mentioning you might get it yeah cuz of
North Korea yeah yeah and he would be
like I love the nobles I love I love
prizes like I love Cracker Jacks comma
Barclays like you'd never believe nuts
and comic with prizes I still get the
happy meal judge with the prize but then
get my noose and to me it's like keep
going is the fun part
sailing a dog on the books a little boy
with this sailor hat isn't that what's
on the cracker yeah yeah exactly and
it's Sarah how could be Sanders has to
come on be like he never said that he
wanted me he liked Cracker Jacks better
than Bazooka Joe bubblegum he liked them
equally that's just got a leak I almost
feel sorry for the woman where she just
said I could wake up every day and now
she loves it look at reporting oh [ __ ]
Sean Spicer I gotta say she's handled
handles it is crazy how compose she
remains but also she I don't think she's
smiled she looks like the type of person
to put on perfume before she takes a
[ __ ] like she just like
something about it doesn't need be on a
t-shirt like something about her just
seems like an orthodox and an ordinary
but she's like look this is how I do my
is how I get up yeah you know I'm
putting on pants but I'm gonna I don't
know either not Iran deal happen today
we're broadcasting so we're now we're
out of that which I'm not smart enough
the most horrible
he's just deconstructing every single
thing Obama did sure and even Obama
responded today in a long Facebook post
so did he shouldn't do that man that was
a good plan the most horrible
terrifically awful president this is the
craziest deal since this woman Diane
from Iowa didn't take the deal on Deal
or No Deal
little how he literally would come I
mean it's like that's nothing you're
right there's nothing I saw undo yeah I
saw a great tweet today where someone
said that if like if Obama wants Trump
to do certain things he should literally
like right now just do the opposite so
if Obama wants gun control Obama should
start you having the NRA yes like just
be like yeah like it's all it bill it's
the greatest thing ever uh guns for
everybody oh well everybody's got a
pretty good mind Anna all of ours are
always yours
yeah they're just impressions of you
know but but I always tell anyone
actress accuracy is overrated it's just
a rhythm and every wants to do Obama and
they lose you chump yeah I mean they're
just accept my Glenn Close is my Glenn
Close you've never done so you want to
hear it I will not ignore does that was
Oh was that it
I don't know I don't have a going close
oh really you know that was good I was
gonna make some up and be like oh
pickles on my burger again you know like
she's never saw one of those things yeah
well the trick they do in impressions is
always to say the name of who you're
doing like hi I'm Glenn Close who can
argue with that that was it I'm goin is
gonna be like a I I know Glenn that's I
told you I'm Glenn Close they got it by
it at least halfway excuse me how much
for that horse I'm Glenn Close I'm
getting close
how to get specific about is there an
impression recently that you've been
[ __ ] around with in your shows that
your mmm or has ever been one that
happens that you just do like I mean all
of them happen I'm just lazy I mean if
look if I was assigned an impression
right like I always like oh I gotta get
John Malkovich but I would have to tape
him and study him but I know there's
something there I think Woody Harrelson
is in so many movies now there's
definitely something there that's just
he's in the next solo movie coming out
he's in every other movie it's in his
global contract but there's voices there
- do you know the only one I did in the
last year was Jeff Bridges cuz I had
seen hell or high water a little foot
long subway GG you know I mean I just
love a guy who's just acting always like
he's just say too much and his belt is
way too tight I stop the old yogurt shop
the way over here and I've laid down
that bottom self-serve coffee ice cream
put on the Reese's Pieces a little
KitKat bar is not healthy Jeff pour in
the gum a bird I put down another layer
see against everything I do is the same
thing I want to take it to madness cuz
that's what I did in high school my
flavors were stoned in the car now are
you weren't stoned with them initially
no later oh my god
no I smoked pot for one year in my life
that's it yeah well why did you stop how
do we get that year but I didn't like
Neil Young's next album I don't you know
what all the Millennials tuned out Neil
who one night I know Neil who's Lincoln
what who the hell's Roosevelt
good guest today and I may get anything
Montana yes if you have an Abe Lincoln
joke cuz I have one I probably did it on
one of these podcasts what is it yeah
what's right because you have to have an
Abe Lincoln joke
do you have to I go he's if there was a
YouTube of grainy YouTube video of
Abraham Lincoln masturbating would he
still have a Memorial and would it be
that large because it'd be a youtuber
that's him
oh that's Lincoln look at the Hat yeah
he's going at it that's he furiously
masturbating just curious yeah that's my
Lincoln chunk it solid Brett God Lincoln
Lincoln off-the-cuff that's it all
that's the joke ya know it's like tough
crowd but it's all Lincoln material I
think Lincoln off-the-cuff is that it
really wasn't Lincoln that's why he wore
these stovepipe hat it was actually a
dwarf up there
ratatouille style just controlling it
but a dwarf wouldn't get elected so they
needed this big tall guy from Illinois
so that's what happened yes so I like
that so that's my Lincoln chunk what
would you want you what would you so
that's my Lincoln coming up on the new
season of that's my Lincoln chunk we've
got Dana Carvey Brad Williams and Adam
ray what would you want your statue if
you could have one erected of you to be
if they put one outside your house or a
cop let's say there's a comedy museum
like the way there is for basketball and
football and baseball no I just think
when I go see the Stars it's gonna be
church lady and Garth yeah and that's
pretty much it I knew George senior I
don't know I think when I go to the
stars remember we all came from stars
and we're gonna return to stars that's
just science not religion you know that
right okay
that's a and I think garlic smoking pot
I told you science its carbon side yeah
yeah I think Garth would be the best
White House press secretary ever oh my
god well they got a bad movie announced
today yeah brother get a sequel I'll do
it for 10 million up front and I'll show
up with pounds on tighten my neck wells
thanks Kerry get Garth out there again
it's that big payday huh
4,200 theaters now the demos trending I
it's funny you bring up it's funny you
bring up Dennis Miller because he was
back in the news recently oh yeah after
the White House Correspondents Dinner
yeah yeah he had a tweet about about
about Michelle wolf right but then it
was the meta joke of like I'm gonna try
to find out who he wasn't get back to
you but yeah but that's how the winner
didn't get the joke
because I I listened to his podcast to
hear what
his neck was on it and yeah it turns out
he was making a joke that just Twitter
didn't get with me it had to be
frustrating that's Dennis it was
gigantic you know Cal Luxor Lutheran
brain or whatever what give me a Dennis
Miller situation or occupation you got
want anything don't even think okay wait
just okay yet Dennis Miller has the
clerk at 7-eleven
it's a clerk what do you mean clerk the
the guys registered yes your password I
work like I'm [ __ ] the 1940 sink well
yes how'd you expect Habib over in here
I can't get the hot dog in the big gulp
over here check your cholesterol
Kent King okay hey in the back we got
the mirrors okay I see you got a KitKat
down your pants all right
okay I need more riffraff in here I'm
getting 850 large I need more people
with weaponry and drug addiction coming
in my skull at 2:00 a.m. okay is Dennis
Miller directing a softcore porn for a
clerk softcore porn for what for a verse
Cinemax yes have to be Cinemax not HBO
and we will know the difference okay
captain large groin let's keep it let's
keep the missile in the pocket okay
we're not going tight on that flame all
right let's get D clothed besides the
little barriers in the crotch area let's
get front don't put the sheet down on
the top of the crack okay coming on it's
a thing I do for my brain mr. Miller
would you like the woman to start
standing up or lying down softcore porn
director yeah some poor kid we don't
have a budget that big tank peeking put
him on the bed put the sheets over let's
get a wide get out of here okay I got a
date with a cappuccino all right
Christ sing standing up sitting down why
don't we got 29 setups our budgets
bigger than that guy Scott no it's
Dennis I'm filtering Dennis now I have
to know if they like cuz obviously
know that I have to know oh wait would
you hat would you do the White House
Correspondents there if hot on his
podcast I guess was floating me out I
don't know if I'd want to follow the
incendiary person because then look at
softy milquetoast
look at this guy with no point of view
with this fluffed up craggy neck out
there with stuff that means nothing and
doesn't offend anybody unless I had
Dennis right my Saddam you know I would
go I wouldn't want to go in his softy
follow-up that's a that was my hashtag
are you in follow it I don't mind doing
it I am I would cross all my stuff is
passive-aggressive and a lot of people
don't even know what I'm saying when I
did the me too thing and I talked about
the strength to Katharine Hepburn no one
understood what I was trying to say is
beat the [ __ ] out of these stupid men
the [ __ ] out of them because they're
coming they're not giving up and by the
way men are obsolete women are gonna
dominate the next six you know which I
yeah I didn't do that on the show but
they are in two generations
oh I've I've got I mean I have a lesbian
friend and her and her wife are having a
child with like in plague and they
barely needed sperm like they had right
you like we're really yeah not useful no
I don't think I think that bio
evolutionary wise women are very
multitasking brains educationally now
that the organizational skills it was in
the bio levers you know was women and
they're graduating college postgraduate
three two two three two one
yeah so now that muscles don't matter
because I was on the tarmac in
Albuquerque and this woman named Tammy
came out in this Air Force jumpsuit and
jumped into an f-16
so she weighed 102 pounds and she could
reign death and terror on a million men
by the way I thought when Isis was out
at peak we should have put women in
bikinis in the f-16s raining down
leaflets saying that's what raining down
was a gay guy and a woman's ring yeah
come on Bridget reload that's pretty
good Mike so getting off on the effect
yeah but anyway women will dominate
Whitman's testosterone will be
eventually reduced will be amorphous
kind of embryonic creatures in the sand
and women will impregnate themselves
they'll grow to six foot eight they'll
be she-beast and they'll dominate the
planet and then we will finally watch
the WNBA because they pass my warriors
could be a WNBA team welcome passing in
threes yeah seen in threes yeah are
where do we go from here I fellas wait I
want to get back to your bad we have
nothing to say I want to get back to
your one-year pot real quick yeah and
what what what was Dana Carvey like when
when he would get a little high um
sillier goofier well you know what
that's uh lock the end it would it chill
you out cuz you're a nut bag is moving
so cool we laugh a lot as humans between
eighteen and twenty-five before life
starts so even when I'm like hiking
Griffith Park I'll see a group of young
people like early mid-twenties
you know and then I'll see people 40 and
up just kind of over so what are they
laughing about yeah and so you just
laugh a lot anyway but yeah I hatched a
lot of bits from that I liked ice cream
I liked movies yeah music mostly I would
say and Neil Young had comes the time
out during that year and which we became
possessed by me and my friends was there
was there a movie or a bit or something
that you remember like or a day like I
can remember a stony day where I laughed
so hard that I mean like I just I don't
remember everything that was discussed
but I remember a couple moments of the
day because it was so right memorable
I don't know I'm wondering I mean it's
more like hallucinogenics which I did
twice you know mushrooms those are what
I remember - yeah that was more stuff
that still lasts yes
now in terms of that's a better high
because at least I got more
introspective well my friends may as
well talk to some bugs we don't get to
do that when you're stuck well we did
the mushrooms and then we
saw the Spruce Goose which is this
however he was the world's Lord walked
around the turn Long Beach and saw this
giant plane and just we fell down
laughing that's the idea that human
being made a plane that big we were just
completely gone they're ours about this
size of the plane and laughing really
hard about the my planes bigger but the
ratio stuff the pamphlet was all about
what could fit it so because the Queen
Mary's there and it's like to show you
how big it is you know be like twelve
hundred bumblebees could get it 3,800
polar bears would fit in this stack
you're like I don't know the size of a
polar bear oh you have a [ __ ] plane
in front of me I just look and see it's
a big step yeah who cares
yeah 2,900 Shetland ponies could fit
into the back we don't give a [ __ ] what
can fit into what [ __ ] seventy-five
thousand polish butt plugs right on the
inside well that's it and then didn't
say you know the Queen Mary could fit
inside the Spruce Goose you know it
became sexual would you ever do uh
characters while you were riding the
high yeah I didn't come from I did we
went to the LA County Art Museum on
mushrooms and I saw a Rembrandt
self-portrait of a Dutch aristocrat yeah
and I thought man he painted him has
such a dick he clearly hated who he was
painting because it was this elite elite
thing and then I started hatching the
voice of of the aristocrat torturing the
artisan who's doing his portrait and it
was like sketch me if you can identify I
shoot you and this went on for hours
and I did it on Sara Night Live and it
was a Conan's favorite sketch oh I did
it the first season sketch me if you can
I done so a and Phil Hartman was the
artist trying to sketch me and I'm
dancing and Lovitz was just the guy
garden puns I'm that was the only one
but mostly in the end of the day most of
stuff comes out just from being tired
Cillian would you write drugs down or
help how did you never really wrote much
down always wrote on stage playing small
clubs though yeah hmm and I realized my
favorite Club is like 80 seats 60 to 80
because I can feel the whole
yeah you know no oh right now yeah yeah
and I'll you know because when you think
about it you know the special I did was
in 1500 yeah it was really it was a fine
Club but for me not good too big to to
the Wilburn that was too big for what I
was doing because I was hatching it in
club so I'm doing you know exhausted
Hitler and I'm really just doing this
tiny thing yeah and then the shots were
very tight and you're a moding and
trying to push it even though I can't
feel the energy I've seen it with other
friends of mine by the way if you have a
certain style where you're kind of a
plaintiff like yelling yeah yeah in a
good way brilliant comics do that like
you know then that's okay but if you're
doing any kind of slightly conversation
subtle things and especially if you're
doing impressions where you're doing a
lot of facial expressions yeah it's it's
gonna be just attitude if you're not
mugging you're just trying to have it
the attitude anyway this is good for the
common items it is I want to ask too
because I'm gonna do my special in the
fall final heads on a style you guys
have a high energy style what size like
what I want to know about to like an
over a mm what's that - last one and
that seems about like I you know I I am
partial to clubs - boom like obviously
theatres a dope and for your first one I
think he does need to look like a little
grant I just saw a buddy of mine did
when it looked like it was almost shot
in a [ __ ] high school theater and I
know what he was going for and I was
like it just did not play to me I was
like I had no idea who he was I'd be
like oh well clearly it's not a big deal
like you do one dealing right yeah yes
like you know I'm thinking like you know
six seven eight hundred maybe is like a
good
that's all it right yeah it but it just
has to feel and trust me because when I
did my first one that Santa Barbara
Theatre that I did was not filled no so
they had to use a couple camera tricks
to make it look like yeah it was filled
and they did thank God what about the
second one
Oh thoughts second when I made a
boatload of money that was filled to the
brim come on but yeah it depends on your
style I've had fun sets in big rooms and
big rooms play different it depends you
know they can play pretty intimate now
are you
because your kids when they open for you
they're doing these larger rooms are you
yeah are you giving them these tips
absolutely I just say if you're like
loudly making a point
mm-hmm like an attorney in a courtroom
with a lot of exasperation and energy
then that's what's required even if it's
the set up you know you just you just
take on that persona I mean you could I
did a special
what are these people coming up to me
yeah you know it's coming from an honest
place though yeah you know but if you're
doing something small that's where it
gets a little difficult you know I I
don't think you have been here since the
LAT when you did my show at The Comedy
Store and just talking about intimate
rooms right you first of all it's just
so and I don't I don't know how much you
think about it but people comment on it
like before and after when you're there
but like when you're back there and you
got your notes and you're going through
it and you're kind of almost seeming
like you're not like prepared at all for
what's about to happen and then you go
out and literally are just there always
looks like there's a somewhat of a game
plan going on but but you keep it so
loose and then you just crush so hard
and then but then but your butt back
there you just look not and even when I
bring you up you're like yeah it's just
like this isn't gonna go like I don't
know what I don't know what's gonna
happen
well the death the comedy is I'm gonna
cross you that's part of its almost
trying to you know well I you know just
where I'm at now is kind of full circle
because I was playing small clubs and
before us you know and I had a structure
I mean I wasn't yeah and then I like
surprising myself in and I like things
coming out a little different as opposed
to brilliant comics who are structural
and word for word which is fine but I
like kind of surprised myself and giving
a sense that anything could happen right
moment yeah but I don't always achieve
that but that's my my goal and I know
that I have a lot of weapons you know
because I can go to these different
voices or attitudes and if you get too
far out if you feel yourself getting
maybe taking to going down risk Avenue
too hard maybe if well if you can you
know my nickname used to be sensitive
man if you can read the room
and since in the moment and then comment
you know it's every comedian has that
somewhere Friday night Late Show where
it's like you're doing your act I'm sure
you guys have had okay I've got my act
yeah but right now I'm just so tired and
couldn't give a [ __ ] that right I'm just
gonna take this path oh yeah whether
it's crowd work or I'm going to extend
this and tag this bit I've done a lot of
times and then my brain just wakes up
even if I'm doing Trump again tonight
because we're going to the club I'll try
to make something different about it to
make myself yes and I do find it really
funny when some people are not really
laughing yeah it really makes me laugh
well it's brilliant because in one of
those Comedy Store shows you had and I
don't know if you can just explain what
happened with that guy man we'd flown in
from Spain I think right yes I've never
seen anything like this in my 11 years
economy this is [ __ ] bomb this was
bizarre for me too
Wow so I'm not there doing all mine yeah
and then there's a guy up front by the
way getting applause breaks like every
set like it was crazy like you always
crush but this was like it was a very
here tonight it was a very good night
and it's nice because the audience is
not totally my demographic so it's kind
of fun yeah you know like as if Bob
Newhart came into a club and crushed
when I was 35 like a new heart you can't
they don't even understand that King
Kong but that night you had a lot of
energy and then I sometimes I'll pass
out my notes to the audience again to
wake myself up yeah because it's and
then you have them pick a bit yeah I
have structured little one-liners and so
with they say Scarface at Thanksgiving
dinner whatever then it puts me in a
surprising mode so it gets me in the
space I want to be in so somehow the guy
mentioned Garth right or Wayne's World
and oh that's what you want so I started
doing it to him this guy in the audience
like what you know and then he mentioned
he was from Spain and I talked about
that whatever his name was and you go to
Spain and you you know you're trying to
do a separation movement Catalan I did
some RIF and then I was moving on to
another bit and I looked over he's in
the front row and I saw that he was
really sincerely suspect sobbing yeah
just sobbing like that and in this
girlfriend whatever had his arm around
him
what what the hell and it goes well he's
from Spain and Wayne's world's his
favorite thing and he was visiting here
and he's just overcome so I brought him
up on stage which always fun it's in the
moment we took a selfie we talked about
it grab my nuts
and that's you know the great thing
about stand-up you you doctor you got
over your go-to because some nights it
just ain't happening but it is it is
loose theater it can be jazz like in the
moment ya know gay nights you can
definitely improvise and it doesn't have
to go the way you wrote it out yeah you
guys have those nights gonna do enough
sets we're like yeah yeah I was just
really connected to it Friday night Late
Show when you can tell that they've been
drinking they don't want to be talked at
they don't want to be performed for with
no material they want they want you to
be kind of loose and that's when you
kind of have to open up and be like okay
well let's kind of play with the way you
want me to I like that how aware are you
that you have global fans like that and
was that like experience just like
because again it's it's somebody your
level your you know that like when you
walk like you could people are gonna
freak out at most instances but like to
get a real moment that has substance to
it like that where there's like this
backstory and finding out that it's his
favorite and he's all this way the odds
of him actually seeing you and and and
and just and having a chat with you
would not even in the realm of
possibility right I had never happened
to me before I can kind of understand I
mean I have friends of movies that are
what bigger than anything I've ever done
but Wayne's World didn't travel yeah
Glenn Close yes what's your pressure
I've never been to Spain great movie by
the way which is in the room yes Michael
Douglas fatal attraction fatal
attraction attraction
no is that true is that is that Michael
Douglas winning no I was trying to do a
Douglas yeah being the try Michael
Douglas yeah Michael Douglas medium
Katherine Jada it's got a little mix it
no not mixing um Regan right when hands
they're little Raymond Douglas that's
the first time I've ever said is there a
little Regan and Douglas well I mean he
had it he had a lot of sex but not that
much
I could only do is dead oh my god nobody
knows who is this there was a guy for
the younger listeners who talked like
this
it was the Moose Jaw and that's the way
Chuck and I did his last movie or his
last big movie him and Kirk Burt
Lancaster is that you don't know that
story so I can't remember what you had
last time on I it was called tough guys
1980 sit was filmed in 85 right before I
got us to know oh my god and I have
played the parole officer with Kirk
Douglas and Burt Lancaster who played
these guys who were in prison for 40
years and then came out of prison and I
walked up to Kirk Doug it's not look him
up kids I walked out to Kirk Douglas
first day at that one point the biggest
star on the Berkeley Burt Lancaster Kirk
Douglas it's like maybe Clooney and Brad
Pitt or even yeah I don't know I don't
know the young Chris hey you're in the
top five of the credits yeah I was the
third lead kind of yeah Eli Wallach was
in there Alexis Smith Charles Durning
and yeah Harvey I was turning but I
hadn't done anything and I was terrified
and they Kirk Douglas I wanna go I'm
Dana Carvey I play rich he goes why
you're perfect exactly what we need for
Russia then I went over to Burt
Lancaster I go I play Richie
how many motion pictures have you done I
go this is my first thing he goes I've
done 72 you doing you've done zero 72
more than you how are you gonna be a
movie star
you got no chin that's one thing he told
me you can't see a movie star without a
chin have you seen Jay Leno he'll be a
movie star he'll pack the center plexus
act I will I mean this movie - yes he
has oh my god I just saw a poster for
today that's so where do you say that he
was in a cop movie he was in a cop movie
did he family said yeah why do movies
tell a joke find out if it's funny a
year later yeah no Jay always had
kind of showbusiness gems about just the
pragmatic he wasn't he was in a movie
this is gonna sound like a mad libs but
this is absolutely true he was in a
movie called collision course where he
played a cop yeah and he was pretty with
with mr. Miyagi Pat Morita wholly yeah
Pat Morita played played the other cop
if this podcast was a podcast where we
watched movies that came up in
conversation during the podcast that's
what we would watch yes ABB's right now
I think I think it's obvious you know
she's the killer yeah he I think he was
actually pretty good but he just he had
that thing like you know stand up like
when I did Jerry show Jerry Seinfeld the
comedians and cars yes like if Jay and I
have a stand-up day what happe I mean
they just love the form yeah in a very
profound singular way he's got the
biggest sitcom in history tonight show
for 20 years but they're kind of like
you know I mean it's kind of cool I'm
yeah they're so pure about this you know
it's cool that no matter what they do
it's still gonna be about stand-up oh
yeah it's not gonna be the thing where
they would do movies and then when the
money runs out then they then they feel
like crap I have right you stand up now
which you see so many times and it's I
mean I get why guys do it they gotta you
know pay the mortgage but it's almost
depressing and you're like we know you
don't want to be here yeah you have to
be well yeah that's that's the thing
that's why I shaved a couple dollars
people say why do you save so much money
I go so I can do whatever I want
yeah well what do you mean you could
have a watchdog twelve fifty thousand
dollar watch on your wrist or be healthy
and be with your family well I'll take
the watch but you know did I use talking
to Conan about this I said look stand up
in it at its core is transporting
yourself someplace else yes when I was a
little kid thinking maybe I could be
funny on TV I never thought the core of
it would be getting my body to another
location because I would do a
one-nighter in Orlando from San
Francisco corporate date go to the
airport flight
delayed two hours lightning storm so
it's basically a 15-hour trip to get to
Orlando yeah pass out for the night get
up psych up with the notes
dude the 45 minutes shake some hands go
back to your room wait and then the
flights delayed another 15 hours getting
back so it's like a 40 hour experience
I'm on stage for 45 minutes so people go
what do you do for a living
I transport myself places and this other
thing happens I barely remember right
but of course you know they earned it
but Jay and you know they're in there
come on it's time to take off yeah I
mean Jay Leno is so unafraid of flying
we have been cheated salami or both yeah
that going into Tahoe a friend of mine I
think Nealon was flying with him and
there was smoke and well we might have
to circle there was a forest fire the
little Tahoe Airport you know I'm not
kidding I told Jay once and again he has
these little pearls of wisdom I said I
have a fear of flying he goes what do
you want to do live forever you know
he's really know Gandhi you know I've
talked to people he's on just the
Russian but he's he says he's totally
relaxed in the same space it like if you
did a brain scan of him yeah matter if
he's on stage in an electrical storm
sleeping it's just completely how do you
achieving that
oh that's just genetic or it's just all
the self delusion I don't know how a lot
of denim I'm in war I'm at war inside my
head all the time
conflicted yeah but you uh you're quite
the outdoorsman your hike with Kevin was
great I'm curious was that I was there
today
oh right Park hiking is that you spot
well it's the best place I've found a
really high cuz I like to hike really
really hard oh really oh yeah how do you
hike back and feel okay well joy you get
you go you have a hill okay and you you
hike with intense purpose okay 14 15
minutes a mile and you don't stop and
you're just your pulse goes up and up
and up so so you're not hiking to be
like outdoors and witness the beauty of
mother no like I'm on a mission I'm most
I'm on a mission I'll do that like in
Northern California out in the redwoods
and stuff but I was a high school track
you know mile or so you're just really
just like everything you get well I've
now
everybody yeah and I just like to get
all this angst out of me by going up
that mountain like I'll do anything to
get to the top of that mountain as fast
as I can it's almost like Brad's
climbing up on a couch well yeah it's
the same it's it's a lot I have a
mission I have something to do I I will
tell you though on that thread nothing
is more fun for me than to walk walk on
an airplane and have the whole plane
just stare at me with my with my who
told me this year today carry-on bag and
and all is a hole the hole blank just
like how is he gonna get that bag up
there Oh interesting how is that gonna
happen and everyone's just sitting down
and then I just I throw down two arm
rests jump up so I'm standing on the
armrest and in one motion just grab my
bag and just huh keep in the overhead
storage bin and then it's the easiest
standing ovation I ever get they
literally apply yes yeah well that's
haven't many times where I just turn
around and you're like oh my god by the
way I love it literally plug because
what if it was boobs yeah Wow last time
we were on Southwest the guy just
wrapped this was a lot better I love
that yeah so yeah you hiked with purpose
I bored with purpose yes did you walk
when you were in Europe you cuz oh yeah
yeah yeah I think yeah I went to no
London Paris south of France it was this
a pleasure vacation or were you doing
some work over there no no I I finally
just sat at this point I'm not coming I
couldn't transport myself for work for
Spain your zombie yeah let though I mean
it's very relaxing the sounds oh let's
do that bad it really is yeah let's do
that it's kind of like well our
socialist place we don't have a Navy
we kiss and [ __ ] go to the beach as I
give cigarettes to baby don't
pepper
retsu good god you guys got in this yes
it is it's beautiful I finished my
stand-up shows the other night I just
started saying that and then you did it
for a long time yeah I'll be back
predominately white of the office Dada
da da everybody retires at 52 praise of
what we're doing how I make love yeah so
I was enamored with that culture now I
like to British now were you walking
around France doing that and trying to
fit in I love not being recognized yeah
and I yeah I basically didn't I have the
hat on and you know but I like London to
and I Somali reports of the of the one I
try sometimes to see if I could order a
pint as a Londoner without did that all
the time when I studied abroad there and
they picked up on it and they were like
um can you stop doing that that's it it
has to be very subtle yeah you know but
I was around enough we'd go well lately
I've been doing McCartney Lennon now
talking about Trump's election who did
they vote for president poll who they
vote is a big orange matter well they
made an orange man Lisa Lisa big orange
man there was a big orange and he's got
a little white things around his eyes
you know and you know if you look at his
hair it's like a big cotton candy goalie
thing you around three o'clock early
afternoon little green sparkles and
purpose vocals come out of his head you
know what do that for eyes do that let's
get back to the show how long could you
go for that if you really if the crowd
was with it how would you let your
san-chan
cuz if I keep going to another topic of
them talking you have things you know I
mean it's just kind of fascinating about
them taking in anything that's going on
in current society
oh it's just it's just something about
that little ting thing and again a 20
year old if they're dying laughing you
know who you know how did he get elected
we got nicknames to everybody you know
you just knocked him down you know like
a shooting gallery you know used to paid
you off at your door
new Pocahontas whatever what would he
call me they'd probably call you Jesus
Johnny or something well that's pretty
funny
you know Jesus so I just like to do them
in my head but I like any rhythm I'm
into is my favorite rhythm is it always
John and Paul you never look like Ringo
slide in life I've never tried we got
Maloney Oh what is she up to what does
she think about long pieces and long
three hundred million nett he was a
contract player in the beginning you
know yeah you get 20 quid a week keep it
simple you know oh yeah and now he's in
the band now he's got 300 million yeah
he was he had no car he had no leverage
at that point
okay put to step up you know where John
Lennon pony's got the coolest Beatle
name - oh yank yeah Oh I mean star with
two R's well I well cuz you know if it's
one R then it's weird yeah I quote this
a lot in terms of trying to figure out
why you guys are friends or who you're
like me with my wife is the cocaine it's
basically it's this sort of
indescribable intrinsic Sensibility yeah
and when they Pete best was kind of the
best-looking guy in the band I don't
know about his drumming but when they
fired him John Lennon's quote was you
know what was the reason and John said
he wasn't a Beatle you know and when you
saw all four of him it was this cheeky
Liverpudlian Irish sense of humor you
know and that's what you know spending
holidays nights and all their little
little colloquialisms and I guess it was
just that that what swing go got in
there plus the best backbeat in the
business you know he rode the kicker
you know he's hitting the kick up you
know and he's staying on the hi-hat
through the break
ashes is no splashes you just riding it
Ringo
sometimes would just stand up because
he's like you know well it wasn't that
tall right yeah it would stand up at the
kit and flail yeah Wow no you are you
playing a lot of good guitar I play
guitar and keyboard every day which is
your go if you're if the day presents
itself for in creative juices are
flowing what's gonna come out first
which instrument now what part of your
body and then
and when well first so I would hike
really really hard almost pass out then
I would maybe try a different tuning on
the guitar put a capo on it and try some
chords I just meditative and then on the
piano which I play like a little kid
it's fun that's really still a new toy
for me you know well even though even
though like it's been in the HBO special
it's been like a party rack sometimes
like do you ever get to nostalgic and
you want to bring it back in well I was
doing the improv
a couple weeks ago and that was the
piano was there I assume it's the
original one in the original position on
stage where I hatched chop and broccoli
I started Northern California but I
didn't have the hook chopped & broccoli
till that room no but and Mark Hamill
was in the audience at and I was pretty
fun to meet him he's funny
very cool but I almost went over there
but Wayne Federman opened who's from my
generation
oh yeah and he loved what he had in here
yeah he's a really great piano guy so I
said how can I go up there and do this
too so I didn't get to it that night but
I will next time that how often are
those memories flashing back when you
get into a room like that like the
original improv I mean cuz that's that's
where you're spending most of your time
when you first got here yeah yeah and I
just think about how much I bombed and
how terrified I was and how intimidated
I was by everybody and everybody seems
smarter and faster and so that never
goes away cuz those those memories will
flood my mind every now and then when I
walk into a certain club like I'll just
like even going to the main room where I
do my once a month show like that's the
first time I ever performed the comic
stores they're gonna bring her show and
Chris Rock actually went up after me and
I went on Facebook that night telling
everybody I opened for Chris Rock told
that story a million times no I've never
heard it yeah that's what it was but
because you know it was a year and a
half in and I was just so you know just
knew but also but so I'll have
flashbacks of that night and other
nights in certain rooms just based on
like a feeling role to take a certain
turn and I'm just like oh man remember
that night when I try when I did this
and it bomb and I went home and I didn't
but but you know or you know the good
with the bad obviously play I'd say it's
just as far as being experiential yeah
trying to become a stand-up comedian on
planet Earth is a very visceral
experience thing so you're gonna have
sense-memory about it it's not normal
it's heady stuff
it's the humiliation and the ecstasy
maybe I can really do this those first
early sets were like I think I might be
able to do this cuz it wasn't a given
yeah you know my first set I killed and
then I bombed 200 I was very typical and
quit a lot you know really so I don't
ever forget that except I tell the
orange now I am a millionaire multi
millionaire if i levitate the room or
played to dead silence it'll have no
impact on my life or anything about me
in any way and my why I said should I
say that my wife cuz yeah you got to say
that yeah definitely they love it when
you say it because it's putting it in
context I I'm out the other side if it's
it's this elliptical thing and I was on
a spaceship I was flying to the center
of the universe and now I'm kind of in
the outer nether read you guys are kind
of in the center near the Sun and you
still are
I try as hard I'm actually more
creatively inspired without that fear
around me because all that dresses
tighten you up yeah and it just makes
you second-guess things that otherwise
you wouldn't now you're at the point now
we're like oh oh I mean hell you're
doing crayon drawings on Instagram yes
watercolor crayons yeah yeah yeah I do
those for my fun for fun on the side
those are very just a little expression
so you go on the route of Jim Carrey and
oh well he's Jewish
he's really doing it yeah I mean I would
like to blow them up and you should like
that like that
I like doing anything creative yeah but
as far as the standup
I'm just trying to make it interesting
for myself and I do you listen to your
sets afterwards you know I was taping
when up before the special right now I'm
just don't even want to think too much
about it I'm not my each night and set
to be its own I'll make little notes
like oh I can build on that you know and
it won't always work but I think that
you know it's just fun to be out the
other side and not be as beholden to the
whole structure of it and I do think
when I watch these the Great's of our
generation Chappell and stuff you know
it's so much a confidence game because
if you you've it you see the presence of
the confidence and the eyes and all that
stuff and you know I always say 99% calm
is great but the last 1% is bigger than
the previous 99% Wow
I don't know if you've had little
moments where like okay I got this oh
yeah and then a couple bad sets or
something gets canceled or some career
thing or something [ __ ] you up and then
you just drop - yeah yeah but then you
you come up a little bit in it's such a
confidence game yeah at its core cuz
it's just you just feel it when the
comedian is not needy and just owns it
and it's so it's so strange to me that
in order to get more confidence we have
we go and we pursue the thing that
everyone is afraid of doing like so many
people are afraid of doing like oh I
gotta get more confidence so to get more
confidence I'm gonna go stand up in
front of strangers and yell at them yes
it seems like magic to people who don't
have the 3,000 sets under their belt
like how in the hell are you doing that
yeah and I get it and when I've taken
long breaks and get like man this is
this is really weird it's always strange
that like Stan said after six minutes
off first setback is always like you're
kind of getting your sea legs about you
again
well cuz they're all facing and looking
and expecting you know but I don't know
if we interesting what happens tonight
oh it's great what that's like hanging
out with buddies right with neelanand
yeah you could do 1015 that he comes up
it's not yeah it is it is what it is you
know is there is there something about
stand-up that that Dex and Tom your
son's have ever because they're not what
three four years in mhm yeah so I mean
it's a game to a point to where you feel
like you can you know because I think
we've all been around like younger
comics and we've been them ourselves
where you've said things maybe ahead of
your time we were like you know buddy
mine a couple years ago he's maybe not
even a year in and he was just like he
was telling me instead of phrasing it
like you know what I'm finding or what's
neat to discover but he was just like
stand-ups this and I was like he was
saying a very blanket statement like you
know what you got to do is you can't
like you can't worry about the crowd I'm
like maybe nine shows you know same but
so have they gotten to a point to where
you can and
a conversation about like if they even
say hey dad we noticed this or whatever
like will you yeah I mean I still coming
up like well you guys in a little bit a
few more years to really have some
perspective before I well I do I do
think that there has to be a period of
time maybe two years where you just do a
crazy amount of sets yeah just to beat
the fear out of you you know ionised is
Marc Maron's podcast he said even the
90s he was very successful by most
metrics he just saw the look in his eyes
and goes I have to get rid of that in
order to go to the next level
Wow and that you just have to do a lot
of sets the other thing is just just
clarity you know if you look at Seinfeld
clarity look at Chris Rock Chappelle
whatever premise they're working you're
not like what what you know it's just
like crazy clarity you're focused and
you know yeah you know yeah and also
just sucking out words you know these
are basics for the premise you know and
also if you're doing a bit where you
have a premise you're supporting the
premise and then suddenly the the jokes
take a little left turn just do a little
little bit of another premise go and
sometimes they say crazy things just a
little thing to guide the audience
because a lot of times all things being
equal with a good audience they'll shut
down if they just don't get it right so
you just want to have that that clarity
unless you're you know trying to go out
there and some acity or offend them you
know anti comedy type stuff which is
fine this this is the kind of stuff and
that in I don't know if you remember
this moment or not but like I remember I
was in the same room as you Robin
Williams and Mort Sahl yes oh I do
remember that the Throckmorton theater
and I was there with my opening act yeah
Jeff Keith and you Robin and Mort Sahl
are talking comedy and I just remember
grabbing Jeff Keith and going don't say
anything because it was just such a
that's a real cool moment to have all to
have all you guys talking and also great
because here three legends and you were
talking about the same insecurities that
that I was having that Jeff was having
that that you have like throughout your
entire career well we don't have the
luxury you know when you see famous
rock-and-roll bands do their setlist
from the 60s or 70s and they have to
yeah it's
like oh man really Wow yeah I mean we
you have to have a new special I mean I
you have to generate new stuff even you
know it's just it's exhausting but I was
always extremely intimidated by Robin
Williams and also Mort Saul's intellect
you know yeah who wouldn't be
yeah but I members I remember you were
going up that night I didn't like that
well and it's like it was pretty packed
yeah and you were in the wings about to
go up and you start shadowboxing and I
go are you nervous and he goes no I love
this I love this and then you went out
destroyed I do always like just a custom
that night I had to because of the
lineup the absolute insane lineup go out
kill how many years no Santa for you
geez at that point probably yes 5 or 6
Byron just enough to feel like you can
do it but just enough to then take in
what's about to happen and go can I do
it
Yeah right where the confidence is like
not generally at that point to where you
just but then you yeah yeah like doing
but also like what am I gonna do not go
out there so yeah you can't you can't
not take that shot yeah you have you
have to know like it oh it always
fascinates me when you see like at the
Comedy Store or The Improv whatever
someone will pop in and go on stage and
just destroy and then you'll see the
comics in the back like oh I'm not going
on now come on you have to go on now
don't you want to be the person that
goes on after Dana Carvey just destroyed
the room and then you kill after that
that's gonna be me tonight I mean I'm
going on at the end it's after Jackie
fabulous I'm trying to get back the
Warriors were yeah oh yes you go first
that's why I mean one of the coolest
things I ever heard about me wanting to
get back and watch the Warriors tonight
is what in Wayne's World 2 we were
trying to get Ed McMahon for your
younger viewers he was a famous sidekick
Oh ed yeah so the idea was ed was gonna
do a cameo world too and the word came
in he was on his boat and he was having
a really good time so he may not do it
mm-hmm if it keeps this it's that nice
on the boat I thought okay that's a guy
was out the other side of show business
yeah he's in this other room just
chilling on a boat it goes yeah maybe
I'll do it and you would take 20s put 5
20s in an envelope
100 our bills and just see package
with envelopes and well they went to
hotels or restaurants how are ya what's
going on and he eventually had a more he
then you go bankrupt right yeah I
remember Jay Leno going he's got a
mortgage she's 87 you know one of the
Morgans name I went I did a sketch with
him at his house where this is laughs
I'll show you that I'll saying the
schedule is amazing we're basically I
had my buddies do these special effects
was basically I was pitching him these
the ideas he's sketch ideas for him to
do a sketch with me and pitch him all
his ideas ik now it's been done it's
been done and I go what about a sketch
where a guy peels back a banana but
instead of a banana there's an apple so
it's a banal and he goes now that's
stupid that'll never work
cut - I'm on YouTube and I see ed
McMahon's been Apple and I click on it
and it said going and he peeled the
banana and they superimposed an apple in
the banan then he just goes what the
hell and then a custome and I go he just
wanted to use it all right we're gonna
wrap this up I'm just trying to make
sure we're not - no we're good show
we're about to wrap it up but we want to
close with requests we'll ask them here
you you prank call the Thai restaurant
as Paul McCartney right amazing when we
wanted to do a a fake movie trailer for
for a for the Trump P tape okay so so
I'm gonna do the the movie voiceover
that's gonna just and they're just gonna
toss in like you know like any trailer
like starring this person in this person
and then right now the trailer and then
it can just be a quick line from the
person who's in the film but it's just
you know it's it's right right yeah you
always put it in yeah yeah just cue me
so here's the this summer find out what
happens when the tape we've all been
waiting for finally hits the Internet
one man two women one Motel six in
Russia
[Music]
come on I'm down here okay you got
gravity on your side do what you gotta
do
where do you want me to pee you know
what you do if I tell you where the funs
all gone okay you do your thing you do
it good many people are saying you're
terrific
okay so just be yourself when everyone
thought the tape couldn't exist it did
you know Here I am okay it was a lot
more than I thought quite frankly okay I
need to tell my hand tell moister
preferable all right okay don't tell
Melania don't tell anybody you're
terrific you're tremendous many people
excuse me
very sad I love you Tony Danza it's
Milania hey I heard there's a P tape
baby is that right no there's not
there's no such thing I'm a germophobe
that's crazy okay that's crazy stuff but
desert people got phases you said you
loved me I don't love anything okay I
love the way my hair lays on my skull
okay that's what I love Michael Kane is
Sarah Huckabee Sanders this [ __ ] is no P
tape there's absolutely no paid tape I
know you gonna say there's a P tape
there's no P tape who keeps saying
there's a PT I tell you this is y'all
fight news Paul McCartney as there is
the hotel manager who found the P on the
bed
Hulu is a beautiful mess upstairs you
know I knocked on the door there was
nothing you're golden with the maid
scheme right and it's just you know
everything's all wet and soggy so you
know unless I said we go to clean it up
we can't put someone in here with this
sort of thing going on Liam Neeson and
Glenn Close as the couple who was
supposed to stay in that room as skewers
have acquired in terms of cleaning up
urine that make me a nightmare for our
prostitutes such as yourself if you
leave now no harm will come to you I'm
not really angry but I talk like this
all the time
and the church lady as the woman who
tried to help Trump find himself after
such a horrendous adventure oh well well
we've got picadillo don't we we've got
little nasty habits don't we well next
time we'll have an umbrella
okay mr. Trump you're right forgive me
God forgive me Jesus too late this
summer the movie we've all been waiting
for
Trumpy tape be there they said it
couldn't happen until it did it's about
last night